video time 2017 Honda Accord had my
remote my or battery in my remote die
changed it out couldn't get the
programming thing to work right would
eventually work for me after trying it
many many times following directions of
you know coming in shutting the door all
that putting the key in turn it on
pressing the lock then doing that three
more times and the fourth time you turn
it on I was never able to get my car
doors to lock and unlock what I was
looking for is there's a light right
here and when I finally got it to work I
actually looked and I turned it on
pressed the lock button a few times
until this light came on that's when I
started my four
turns and each time I pressed it when I
turned it on all the way pressed the
lock I watched for the light and
sometimes I had to hit it a couple of
times a little
harder and um did that the four times
again my Lo lock and unlock didn't work
so what I did is I got out of the car
and just walked away a little bit maybe
to get the proximity thing away from the
car and then walk back to it
and hit lock and unlock and started
working so again just that little red
light right there I don't know if it's
my keys my buttons issue with that but
again it did not do the lock and unlock
automatically like the direction say
from like dealerships and stuff so uh
mine's fully functional now hopefully
it'll help some of you guys